Monday PFT ot week 14 is done we got
plenty of things to get to that we
didn't get to during the two hours that
we're on NBCSN but let's begin with the
game of the year because there's still
some things unpack and we touched on
this a little bit but I want to focus on
it okay
48 246 final score exciting game right -
high scoring yeah how concerned should
the 49ers and the Saints be about their
defenses based upon what they did or
didn't do on Sunday I don't think they
need to be that concerned one I think
those are really one of the two or three
offenses that maybe could even do that
to them in football is right there so I
don't think it's a big picture problem
for either one I really don't I still
think the 49ers and Saints are still one
of the better defenses on football I
think this was just one of those days
one where you know a big matchup and two
guys in Sean Payton and Kyle Shanahan
who just knew they were playing a really
good football team knew they were
playing a really good play caller on the
other side and that added to them more
wrinkles more creativity we got to push
the limit in this football game and it
kind of went from there I would not be
shocked if they played in the NFC
Championship game and went back to like
twenty three twenty something like that
I don't think I think this is one of
these things that both of these teams
will learn from but I think it's the
first first time all year these defenses
how to play really really high octane
offenses and I'm not necessarily
concerned with the defense's overall
we've seen the Saints give up 28 yeah 27
right 27 yeah there was a little how the
Cowboys at 10 they got 24 to the box
right
they had that 13 6 game against the
Jaguars that really is the outlier here
25 to the Bears it was a lot of garbage
time points say they blew out the
Cardinals 31 to 9 they lost at home to
the Falcons giving up 26:17 to the Bucs
on the road which is impressive because
the Bucs were capable of scoring 40 in a
game 31 of the Panthers 18 to the
Falcons and now 48 to 49 I think I were
concerned with them with the Saints
because I I also think that the 49ers
offense is less prone to sputtering than
the Saints I feel like the 49ers are
always going to get their points yeah
right yeah
even against the Ravens in the way in
the rain they got 17 points right right
yeah no I agree with you there's so many
weapons right now in the 49ers office we
know Shanahan's awesome but you know
Jimmy Garoppolo playing well he can push
the ball down the field but then we've
taken Emmanuel Sanders debo Samuels born
Kittel moats dirt Breda you just go holy
cow I mean who do you stop on that
offense so I'm with you there the Saints
defense as of late has and I've said
this on my podcast a little bit has
scared me a little
there's no doubt about that I think
their biggest problem is in certain
situations they just can't trust their
secondary to play man-to-man Marshawn
Lattimore is the only guy they can
really trust in those situations PJ
Williams Eli Apple as we saw you know
Gardner Johnson trying to cover George
Kindle on the 4th and 2 you know they're
just not good enough man-to-man corners
to make stops on 3rd and 4:30 and 5
against the really good quality offenses
in football and that's when you need to
pipe man-to-man is in those situations
so you take away those short type of
passing plays and things like that so
I'm definitely more concerned with the
Saints defense but not as a whole
because I just look at it and I go you
know these are two elite elite offenses
with two really elite head coaches and I
just don't know if there's a lot of them
out there to be able to expose either
one of these defenses like that again
one other wrinkle we haven't discussed
yeah game Western Richburg started oh
that hurt injured and Kyle Shanahan said
after the game it doesn't look like it's
going to be good I haven't seen it seen
anything specific but yet carted off and
when the coach says something like that
that means the preliminary evaluation by
the doctors has resulted in that you
know they're concerned you know we have
time oh they're concerned he has a torn
ACL and and that's going to be the worry
it is it's a huge position for that
often yes why well because it's a
Shanahan asks a lot of the center you
know we know the run game and the
inside-outside zone you need to be very
athletic think about it this way when
Kyle Shanahan was with the Atlanta
Falcons one of the first things they
didn't free agency was get Alex Mack
right
because hey they're gonna throw screens
they're gonna run on the edge and of
course they're gonna run up the middle
too so you need to have a center that's
very versatile that way and Western
Richard Berg's one of the better ones in
football they paid him a lot of money
they paid him like he's one of the best
one out there so that's a that is a blow
to their team because
offensive line is really where it all
starts and shanahan through the run game
and everything he does there now the kid
they got I think it's been garland 63 he
comes in he's not a bad player he was in
Atlanta with Shanahan there too so
understands the system and all that but
Westin Richburg is a pretty special
talent at the center position and they
have overcome injuries all year long and
they made no excuses yo right they've
got that right attitude which is next
man up and no excuses and we're not
gonna feel badly for ourselves but they
have gotten through that they've gotten
to this record of 11 and 2 with George
kiddo missing time yeah with other key
players missing Tom price Joe Staley
missed weeks than any Missy for time
sweet Dee Ford gone Mike McGlinn she's
been gone I'll use chicks been gone
right it's amazing and they just keep it
rolling they just keep it going but and
I think they will keep it going and
you're right I think it's going to be
49ers Saints in the NFC Championship
game the question is will it be in New
Orleans or in San Francisco either way
though and then the other point we made
I mean I know it's important to have
home-field advantage but in that Saints
Seahawks 49ers round-robin they've all
played each other and the home team's
our own three right so maybe home for
their to the Packers set into there
which is crazy because they're the
number to see the pack below them right
but look what happened to the Packers
when they play Niners no in in Santa
Clara and I think the yeah I don't think
the Packers would fare much better if
they're in New Orleans or in Seattle
either I would scare me
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports